here's Whoopi Goldberg completely lying
about the thing
trying to get through everything that's
happened over the weekend and what's all
the insanity going on in the world like
Wednesday uh Florida's Board of
Education approved
what they're calling standards for uh
African-American history I feel like
they didn't talk to any
African-Americans because we could have
told them about the history and nor have
any anyone seemingly gone to the
Smithsonian we're telling you this
history it's our American history
because you need to know so we don't
repeat it and here you come to Santa's
trying to repeat away you know what as
long as the Smithsonian is standing as
long as there are books as long as there
are families because remember we didn't
have books all these stories come to us
from our families you don't call our
families Liars they know what happened
because their Grandma's Grandma's
Grandma's Grandma told them you sir are
you are I can't I can't even say the
word you're a disgrace we'll be right
back all right first off Whoopi you
gotta lay off the pipe I've heard from
multiple sources you show up to that to
show stoned every day
um I don't know what the high hell
you're talking about DeSantis is not
trying to reinstate Institute slavery or
teach anyone that slavery didn't exist
or anything like that but you flat out
lied when she said that they should have
talked to some black Scholars about this
uh because two of the scholars that were
on the board who put this whole
curriculum together and by the way we're
going to read you some of the curriculum
and link to it down below you will find
it is it in the description already yeah
it's in the description already if
you're watching this video right now
we've already linked to it don't what
don't read it while I'm telling you
about it but yes there are two Scholars
who are black they are African-American
Dr William B Allen and Dr Francis
Presley rice so everything you just said
there was complete nonsense
[Music]
thank you